oh well make it I getting bit camera
methods that is here with some stars who
definitely fit that bill Justin Bieber
and Kendall Jenner yeah they are in
pretty good shape and yet they are
showing off a new Calvin Klein campaign
and listen they're sexy and they know it
what makes life sexy just being able to
be yourself
yeah I know being sexy is just being
100% comfortable with yourself just in
dreaming and nothing but is Calvin's
you're welcome ladies I am fearless by
taking things one step at a time and not
focusing on the hardships but focusing
on the success and Kendall inspiring
some body and I know it was sick and
amazing and it honestly I wear it every
night to sleep the new spring global ad
campaign featured celebs and street
artists answering the question what do
you do in your Calvin's seems us Justin
puts Greek statues to shame he tagged
this one flan while rapper Kendrick
Lamar reflects I am Calvin
Compton means strength you know you got
to be a strong person to grow up in that
inner city I want to be with you is how
Kendall fills in the blank the campaign
marks both her and Justin's second
go-round with the labor feels so good to
be back with Calvin Klein
you